recently satellite cameras exposed a
well hidden secret in the rainforests of
africa distinct clearings buried deep
within the forest these strange islands
are located in a northwest corner of the
republic of congo where an expanse of
lush vegetation makes up odds ala
national park the Westerners were
unaware of these clearings local people
call them bys in the dim morning light
creatures cautiously approached the by
it's a group of western lowland gorillas
a large male sports a waistcoat of white
hair a symbol of his dominance at more
than 300 pounds this silverback rules a
harem of unrelated females and family
members on any given day several groups
may share the bye in peace but the
equilibrium is fragile here and easily
upset this morning a young solitary male
is also on the scene he Swagger's in
perhaps for a drink and a bite to eat
but to him the bye is also an attractive
singles bar a place where he can I the
market of potential mates the young
females give him the once-over and he
conducts himself with style casually
moving to an even better vantage point a
dominant silverback has enormous
responsibilities looking out for the
welfare of his group his family relies
on him for guidance for leadership for
protection any challenge to a
Silverbacks Authority is a potential
threat to the stability of his family
this one tries to ignore the intruder in
their midst but how long can he hold out
with a rush of confidence
the single male dances across the by
creating a spectacle
the silverback has seen enough they
silently but aggressively face-off
far out matched the young male turns
tail and runs calm restored the by
returns to its more peaceful state